now the chancellor of the exchequer
reportedly tried to have Ian Duncan
Smith fired four years ago but the work
in pension sec or tree is he then was
refused to leave that's according to an
excerpt from a new book about what went
on behind the scenes in the coalition
government years and it was written by a
man who was at the very heart of it the
former lib dem Minister David Laws he's
ripping out very good morning to you mr.
loss so what did you say what's in the
book about this it seems like a pretty
toxic relationship between George
Osborne in in Duncan Smith what did you
see of that yeah I think it's no secret
that the two of them have never really
got on as individuals but running
through this was a big tension about
policy the Chancellor in a sense trying
to do his job saw essentially the
welfare budget as a huge cash cow that
could be milked in order to deliver
saving this to reduce the budget deficit
Ian Duncan Smith's focus really as
welfare secretary was much more on
welfare reform getting people into
employment and some of that involves
spending more money so he was far less
enthusiastic than George Osborne about
cuts and often in the coalition
government actually the Liberal
Democrats and Nick Clegg would end up
vetoing the cuts to the Treasury one is
he I mean I've read an unnamed
conservative ministers comments this
morning saying that in Duncan Smith
actually mrs. the lib dems I think if
only does because we were protection
from some of the worst and most extreme
George Osborne cuts Ian knew that even
if he couldn't see them off Nick Clegg
most certainly could veto them and we
often did so what's obviously happened I
imagine is since we've gone from a
coalition government to a conservative
only government Ian no longer has the
Liberal Democrats there to protect his
budget I don't think we would have had
ludicrous policies such as the plan cuts
in tax credits that we saw George
Osborne try to deliver last year if the
lib dems have been there and I think
that this must have made in the can
smooth feel a much more lonely and
vulnerable figure in the government much
less able to defend his own departmental
budget anything on the on the George
Osborne said he always had the knives
out even during the coalition years for
the Liberal Democrats a couple of things
he said during the course of that budget
speech which some seemed a bit well you
know ungracious to say the least when he
talked about he tried to make it as a
joke saying you know when the former
pensions minister
steve webb lost his seat he said I was
trying to abolish the lump sum instead
we're going to keep trying keep a lump
sum and try to abolish the Liberal
Democrats well politics is a tough our
business so I don't resent George his
little joke the fact is there's always
been a big difference in perspective
between the lib dems and George Osborne
about what budget priorities should be
and also born I think is in trouble this
week within Duncan Smith and with the
country because he and David Cameron
have always been focused on and obsessed
by the interests of those on
upper-income as always trying to give
them breaks in budgets we saw that right
throughout the coalition years at a time
when we should have been protecting
those people on low incomes from
austerity and we sought to do that in
coalition and yet in the last week
George Osborne is giving away billions
of pounds in tax cuts on things like
capital gains tax which helps people on
upper-income actually makes tax
avoidance much easier because of the
difference between income tax and
capital gains tax rates at the same time
as he's trying to make these huge cuts
in the incomes of people reliant upon
disability benefits and I think that a
lot of people in the country let alone
Iain Duncan Smith think that that is
very unfair and want to push back
against them just to pick out one of the
one of the headlines there from the
exits from the book today about the
National Health Service it seems to be
in some almost chicane really going on
there you I you identify that
conservatives leaning on Simon Stephens
chief executive and the NHS in England
and Wales just tell us about that this
is a huge issue and it's not just about
history it's about where we're going to
be with the NHS over the next few years
in 2014 the standards in the NHS were
beginning to slip because their budget
was on the real pressure after a number
of years of being protected but not
seeing increases and our focus was to
try to increase the budget in the last
year of the coalition Simon Stephens the
chief executive of the NHS decided to do
a piece of work of his own estimating
how much the NHS needed over this
Parliament and he came up with a figure
of about 30 billion pounds which i think
is sensible and he thought he could make
about half of that 30 billion in
efficiency savings and that he needed
about 15 billion or 16 billion from the
Treasury
the message he then got from the
conservatives in Downing Street was no
way the Chancellor and Prime Minister
will give you 15 or 16 billion that's a
huge sum if you come out with something
like that will just rubbish it and
discredited you need to bump up the
efficiency savings that you think you
can make and reduce the the figure that
you need from the Treasury 28 billion he
did that and as a consequence we're now
assuming as a country that we can make
three times the efficiency savings in
the NHS that we have done over the
entire period of the NHS being in
existence which I don't think anyone
serious thinks we can do unless we
change that and get serious figures for
the IHS budget we're going to see
waiting times go up and service
standards go down mr. Lewis sorry must
end it there but thank you very much
indeed for those insights David Laws
there